if ever in his life oh by the way Joe is
a gay man who is polyamorous so he had
two husbands mm-hmm
both husbands apparently we're not gay
yeah it's just that's so [ __ ] that how
everyone is using each other yeah cuz
one of them was like [ __ ] the
receptionist in the front and the other
one was just like free meth and drugs
they were all [ __ ] meth heads doing
crazy meth together so one of his
husband's you'll see him in the
documentary he yeah you just assume he's
gait throughout the whole thing but
towards the end he goes up and die and
women my whole life
since I was in kindergarten all the way
till high school I was I was with women
yeah I was like so you're not gay my gay
other husband was a 90 no kid from
Southern California was he yeah he's
from California damn that one that yeah
that nineteen old kid Wow and then I
think what they were saying that he was
just basically doing it for free drugs
and just get being able to live with him
to do had the biggest [ __ ] hands yes
he was huge
big ass has size 16 feet yeah he was he
was like six foot six yeah
giant dude and it wasn't gay he wasn't
good he wasn't [ __ ] gay spoiler alert
for those he [ __ ] kills himself and
it's caught on camera yeah so they
noticed that he threw out this this
documentary is [ __ ] crazy yeah man I
can't like it's hard to it's hard to
describe this Dogma is so [ __ ] crazy
it started one of the things that I
noticed was in the doc they didn't have
any personal interviews of that husband
really that the one in Oldham sorry
right because he [ __ ] killed himself
away there wasn't any to take from him
so he was showing a lot of signs of like
depression he was being really weird
they said that he was just he the cat he
would just walk around point him doing
that he said what time he I woke up and
he had a gun in my face
yeah and so I guess that day the footage
that they have the cameras kind of not
faced towards him so he kind of goes off
camera and before he actually shot
himself he was pointing the gun at the
campaign manager they were actually
really close friend
they became really close after he
started working for Joe and then he goes
he'll get that gun out of my face like
don't [ __ ] play around like that heal
him do nothing and he starts swinging
the gun around then he puts it in his
face mm and then boom boom bust his
[ __ ] head open with his gun right
dies immediately and the campaign
manager is like it's nothing like you
see in the movies
mm-hm sat there with his [ __ ] mouth
open the whole time I didn't know what
to say that was a prank or something
like that he's gonna believe it just to
show you how hilarious his documentary
is after he dies they do the funeral and
the Joe exotic he starts singing his
country music at the [ __ ] funeral and
he was making jokes yeah I was like
golden nugget about it did a eulogy
about his ball sack and how beautiful
they were he's a you know what I'm
talking about I'm sure everyone's seen
his balls yeah all those beautiful
golden minutes
his mama's is crying
this dude is he just killed him son the
funeral he's doing the eulogy and in his
eulogy he just talks about his [ __ ]
beautiful testicles yeah you cannot make
these people up these are real [ __ ]
human beings I'm sure y'all know about
his beautiful gold everybody salut and
then two months after that there you go
he gets married again he gets married
again to some other young man Dylan
Dylan Dylan he's gay for sure though yes
kids gay for sure he's gay for pay yeah
yeah in love with him he marries at two
months later he gets his ex exes or his
husband who passed away Travis yeah uh
mother mother to come to the [ __ ]
wedding
it's just her yeah and Hammerman in the
camera man that's it yeah and after that
he never so he was just and she said
that she felt like she was used because
he just wanted proof that she had
approval yeah then he can move on and
all us that is so [ __ ] garbage my
guys [ __ ] oh did you guys also know that
he ran for the President of the United
States
that's what we they're in the traffic
Clinton this is recent guys this is
[ __ ] recent yeah so he ran for
president that's why I'm in he had a
campaign manager the campaign my
girlfriend to run for presidency mm-hmm
and then because he realized he wasn't
gonna do that he wants to be governor
yeah that was fun that was fun which was
[ __ ] crazy because like you know what
we're gonna do to Isis the dummy were
like uh whatever that thing and then he
just blows it up he has a habit of
blowing [ __ ] up by the way there was a
part two where when Carroll was suing
him for a million [ __ ] dollars and he
had no assets he starts you know
obviously he's recording himself every
day and he just goes you want to get
what I have I don't have anything you
want my bed cuts to a seat and blows up
his bed my watch it's ridiculous yeah I
can't even get my - those scrambled with
this this damn show I it's weird because
I know the allure of wanting to pet a
tiger rim dad I forgot where I was I
think I was in Japan and then they had
this thing where you were behind the
glass and you could pay to pet a tiger
am i [ __ ] this up with reality or is
this a dream because I feel like Gina
was there and then I think Gina was the
one that told me like yo they actually
kind of drugged them up and you know
that's why it's it's really inhumane but
if Gina wasn't there I would have petted
that tiger
I feel like Gina did post him like that
yeah it's like super inhumane I'm not
gonna lie yeah well that's what he did
when he was running what was it didn't
you bring him to like the Chamber of
Commerce doesn't like that yeah yeah to
like he's also magician too by the way
was it oh my god he was with Jude he's a
pizza owner gay Gunn right owner pizza
parlor owner tiger sanctuary duty also
his magic
dude I can't there's so much there's so
much [ __ ] about this guy it's [ __ ]
unreal and then the other dude who was
the doctor of mystical arcs dr. Antle
he's also polyamorous he has a bunch of
girls oh you know that guy that I said
I'll [ __ ] UM the guy who who has says
he was like no duh he said something
[ __ ] funny - he goes when I met doc
antal he was asking me is like well do
you want to learn how to take care of
cats he goes I already know how to take
to get that type of cats I'm trying to
figure out how you get [ __ ] how to get
the cats out how to get [ __ ] because
you would have like four or five
different hotwives how are you talking
about this guy that guy was like a cult
leader so there was like women who would
work for him and he had a house for each
each girl that he was with I and and one
of the girls that was being interviewed
she was forced to get a boob job
got about her yeah she got it - she got
a boob job she got everything else and
she was a little weird herself yeah and
it's funny because she was talking about
how oh when I look for this job oh yes
the Craigslist people was the guy who
was the zum-zum Anna Jersey zoo keeper
he goes I it was that really weird
skinny guy with the he was the one that
eats all the food from the from Walmart
oh yeah yeah yeah it was like when I
looked up for this job I found it on
Craigslist
I never done this before [ __ ] yeah and
then he's the manager of the zoom yeah
just like there's another guy too when
you look at the documentary he has to
fake legs and I was like oh [ __ ] this
[ __ ] got eaten by Tigers and
there's like a lot of people think that
I got my legs eaten by Tiger zip-lining
accident and then busted his spine and
he had a beet ate his legs and there was
the other girl how do you remember all
this craziness it was so intense yeah
there was that one of the other zoo
girls she lost her arm one of the 100
yeah I liked her she actually could have
saved her arm and she was so down for
Joe exotic so just to put this in
perspective there was a point where um
she got her arm mauled by a [ __ ]
tiger world is basically done but she
decided
she loved the tiger sanctuary so much
and she knew that there was a lot of
animal rights activists trying to take
down a sanctuary that it was taken about
two years for her to rehabilitate her
arms so she could use it again or they
could have amputated it as she could
have gone home in a couple of weeks the
reason why she decided to amputate her
arm and not save her arm even though she
could have kept it was because that if
she stayed in that hospital a lot of
reporters would have came and they would
have dragged out [ __ ] on the tiger
sanctuary so if she if she caught
forearm went back to work like she was
completely fine with it
it would have died down yeah and so she
sacrificed herself for that [ __ ]
sanctuary yeah that's how much she loves
that [ __ ] yeah she was brainwashed
brainwashed but you know she towards the
end like when they interview her because
they asked her like do you think he
would have the ability to hire someone
to kill Carol he's like no did you have
any no and then cut - so how are we
gonna kill her she carols on this route
he's soaked her out with a blow dart
it's like $3,000 yeah $3,000 is like
nothing like I've never tried to hire
somebody to assassinate someone but I'm
pretty sure it would not cost three
thousand [ __ ] dollars
it was so [ __ ] dumb yeah three
thousand dollars and then he was like
well what he's like I just walk up to
her - parking lot and the shooter yeah
it that's the whole [ __ ] elaborate
plan mm-hmm-hmm I wish I remember the
name of the weird-looking guy damn I
that guy looks so [ __ ] funny man I'm
gonna be informant for Joe exotic then
Jerry know he was so weird-looking if I
just put fat weird guy I'm pretty sure
he would pop up Joe exotic curly in jail
right now
he's a actually I did see someone on a
Twitter that he's still posting from
jail